you
you
so good morning I hope everyone's had
their coffee we've got a lot to cover
here I'm glad we got started pretty
quickly so we should be good so I
realized that the term static
metaprogramming probably requires a
little bit of explanation so how many
people know what metaprogramming is so a
pretty good chunk of you so
metaprogramming is basically writing
programs that manipulate either
themselves or other programs as data and
usually when we talk about meta
programming we're talking about things
like you know hooking getters and
setters and customizing method dispatch
languages like Ruby and small talk
really allow you to kind of reach into
the runtime and do some funky things
what I want to talk about today is not
this kind of meta programming but rather
programs that manipulate code so that's
kind of a different type of meta
programming which some people call
static meta programming so a thing that
manipulates code a compiler is actually
a really good example of that right a
compiler is a thing that takes code in
and outputs code now normally a compiler
is something that takes in some sort of
high-level code and outputs something
lower-level so a C++ compiler you know
spits out machine code and a Java
compiler spits out Java byte code but
you know you can also compile to another
high-level language probably a lot of
you familiar with CoffeeScript right
which just compiles to JavaScript and
there's a ton of other languages that do
this people sometimes call these
transpilers it's basically just a
compiler it's the same thing so compiler
basically consists of two main parts the
first thing is the parser so the parser
takes source code and it creates some
sort of structured representation of
that source code usually we call this a
parse tree or an abstract syntax tree
and the second main part of a compiler
is a code generator so the code
generator takes a parse tree you know
does some analysis on it walks over it
and spits out the object code and of
course this is this is a pretty big
simplification in particular there's
usually a lot of stuff that happens in
that middle step there of analysis and
optimization those things but like I
said you know we don't we we don't
always have to compile from a high level
language to a low level language we can
compile you know to another high level
language or we can compile to the same
language that we started with and this
is what I want to talk about next so I'm
going to show you some examples of using
JavaScript compiler called
s prema prema is a nice simple fast
compiler for JavaScript but it's also
written in JavaScript which is kind of
cool
so you can you can dive in and check out
the source and understand what it's
doing and Esprit m'a also has two
related modules
yes Traverse and es Co Jen so so es
Traverse is a module for traversing the
parse trees that are generated by us
prima and es Co gen is for doing code
generation from the parse trees and
we're gonna use both of these in the
examples that I'm going to show you so
this is a really really simple example
of what you can do with this prima has a
nice simple API right we require a
Suprema or include the source tag and
just call the parse function so this is
a very very simple JavaScript program
here write a single function that
returns a value Esprit MA is going to
emit a parse tree that looks something
like this this is a bit of a
simplification but at the top level we
have a program the program consists of
one thing a function declaration the
function declaration has an identifier
the name of the function and it has a
body the body has one thing which is a
return statement and it returns 42 so
this is sort of a simplified version if
you want to see it in its full glory
I'm not sure if that's big enough to
read but you get the picture it's you
know there's a lot of detail there to
the parse tree so on its own this is a
little bit boring right okay so we parse
JavaScript and we get a parse tree who
cares but it turns out that if we if we
actually do stuff to this parse tree we
can we can analyze it and do a lot of
useful and really interesting things and
I'm going to show a basic example here
which is to do a style checker so this
is sort of an example of how something
like jslint works and so as Brian
mentioned I work on the chrome team at
Google and on the chromium project we
have style guides and we have a C++
style guide and a JavaScript style guide
and they're not quite the same variables
in C++ have underscores and in
JavaScript we use camel case so I find
myself getting mixed up sometimes
between these style guides and you know
really wastes a lot of time in code
review when you realize that you used
underscores when you should have used
camel case
so I wrote a style checker that can that
I can run is a pre-commit hook to
prevent me from making these mistakes
and I'll show you just how easy it is to
do this with a spray map so that's
basically the code right there it's
about 15 lines of code and it's really
pretty simple so the first thing we do
is just call the Esprit ml parse
function to to parse the parse the code
and get back an abstract syntax tree and
then we use the es Traverse module to
walk over the syntax tree now yes
traverse can basically does a
depth-first traversal of a parse tree
and you can visit each node either on
the way down before you visit its sub
trees or on the way up and and in this
case we're doing it on the way down it's
not really relevant but that's just the
meaning of the enter why we're using
enter there so this function that we
have here is going to be called for
every node and we're just looking for
nodes that are variable declarations and
when we find that node we're going to
call the check variable names function
and again this is pretty simple
so a variable declaration can have more
than one variable that it declares right
so we're going to iterate through each
of those and we're just gonna call a
function for every single one and I'm
basically just looking to see if the
name of the variable has an underscore
in it and if it does that's an error
that I want to report so I'm just gonna
push this errors object to an array and
at the end of the script I report all
the errors that were found so that's it
really really simple and short now have
some sample code here that I want to
test against and if I run these scripts
on that codes lo and behold it detects
the errors and and and spits me out a
warning so this is just a really simple
example of the kind of style checks you
can do as I said you know this is
basically the way jslint works and so if
you have a style guide in your project
you know you could imagine writing a
style checker that will check every
single aspect of your style guide and
it's really not that complicated to do
so this is an example of analyzing the
parse tree right so we read in the code
we analyze the parse tree but we left
the original code intact so the next
thing I want to do is something a little
bit more interesting which is to
actually rewrite the source code and
what I'm going to do is I find so I find
often when I'm developing I'm trying to
understand the flow of my code and how
it flows between functions and
especially if I have a lot of callbacks
and we can get really complicated and I
like to insert logging statements and
probably a lot of people do this but
sometimes it's super annoying to have to
go and insert logging statements in like
10 or 15 different places so I wrote
this little script that basically adds
logging to every single function in a
particular source file and again it's
actually surprisingly simple to do this
so again we we first take the source
code and we parse it into an abstract
syntax tree then we're going to walk
over that tree and look for particular
nodes so this time we're look
for function declaration nodes and
function expressions and when we find
one we just call this this function add
before code so this function is a little
bit more complex than we had before you
know we're not just reporting errors so
first we figure out the name of the
function and then what I do in the
second line here is to build up a string
that contains the code that I want to
insert at the beginning of every
function so it's just a console dot log
statement with the name of the function
but you could do some more sophisticated
stuff here with you know printing the
values of the arguments to the function
now the next line is is interesting I'm
actually going to take this string that
I built up and use this prima to parse
it and so I'm going to have a little
parse tree a very very tiny parse tree
that I'm going to use an insert into the
original parse tree so to get an idea of
what what we're doing here the original
parse tree is something like this and we
have a function declaration its body is
a block statement and that has a body
which is an array of statements and
those statements represent basically
every single line in the function so my
mini parse tree that I created from that
string that I built up is actually just
a single statement object and I'm going
to take that and I'm going to add it to
the array at the beginning of the array
that represents the body of the original
function so I've modified the original
parse tree here and then the next step
to actually do something useful now that
I've modified the parse tree is to Amit
Amit code so using the es cogent module
I actually generate new source code from
the original from the modified parse
tree so I took in the original code
modified the parse tree and I'm spitting
out some new JavaScript and then I can
you know run that JavaScript and it's
gonna log all the function enters so
just a simple example to show you what
this is doing here right here's a simple
simple snippet
that contains two functions and if I run
my little script on this it spits out
two new code that looks almost the same
except for the fact that it's got these
console dot log statements at the
beginning of each function and this is
done completely automatically right so I
could I could do this across a thousand
source files if I wanted so this kind of
stuff is really really powerful I think
for doing the kinds of things that maybe
you know Java people will do with with
Eclipse refactoring tools I've shown
just a couple examples here but really
there's kind of no limit to what you can
do when you're manipulating these parse
trees but these are all examples of
basically compiling from JavaScript to
JavaScript so I want to get into
something a little different which is
what if our source language is not
JavaScript maybe some of you you know
I've always dreamed of creating your own
language
something like CoffeeScript maybe that
compiles to JavaScript right it's a
really really simple and powerful way to
create a new language and to play with
language concepts and for that I'm going
to show you how you can use parser
generators so parser generators a
personal generator is basically a thing
that takes a language grammar as input
so language grammar is just you know a
formal description of a language and it
spits out a parser that will parse that
language and you've probably heard of
some of the more famous percé or
generators yak bison or JavaScript
there's Dyson but today I'm going to
show you an example of something called
peg das which is a which is a slightly
different kind of parser generator that
uses parsing expression grammars trying
to explain very briefly so let's talk
about these grammars it's basically you
know if you're going to write a new
language you
need to know how to deal with formal
grammars so how many people are familiar
with this kind of syntax for
context-free grammars
okay so quite a few of you this is
basically a meta language it's a
language for describing languages and if
you're designing your own language or
you're even looking at other languages
this is the kind of thing that you'll
see quite a bit what I have here is an
example of recognizing an arithmetic
language so basically just sort of math
expressions you can have numbers you can
have plus or minus operators
multiplication division and brackets and
you'll see if you're familiar with
regular expressions you'll see that some
of the similar syntax is used in
context-free grammars now me maybe
you've seen these in slightly different
forms there's Backus noir form and EB n
F they're slightly different but they're
really just different representations of
the same thing so this is the form that
I'm going to use today but first I want
to talk about one particular thing this
little this what we call the choice
operator so this is basically works like
a logical or in most programming
languages except the one difference is
that in context-free grammars it's
actually unordered so it's not like a
short-circuiting operator like you have
in programming languages and this is
because context-free grammars come from
linguistics actually you know they
weren't computer scientists who
originally came up with these things an
implementing unordered choice it can be
a bit of a pain and sometimes you have
language ambiguities and so there's a
slightly different variation called
parsing expression grammars and that's
what we're going to use today and pegs
use ordered choice so it's it's just
like the logical operator in a
programming language so if the if the
first option is used then we don't even
bother looking at the second option and
to indicate
that the operator is ordered choice they
usually use a slash instead of the
vertical bar but it's it's a minor minor
syntax difference so let's take a look
at what it looks like to use peg KS to
parse this arithmetic language that we
have so you can just take the string and
call the build parser function and it
will return you an object which is a
parser and then I can use this parser
just like I use the Esprit my parser to
parse jsr to parse my new language and
if i if i try and test out this code so
try and parse one plus ten actually get
an error and this is something that if
you use parsing expression grammars a
lot of people are going to run into this
the first time they try something and
it's an error about left recursion and i
think it's worth explaining why this
happens because so many people run into
it it's actually very simple so a lot of
parsing expression grammars are tools to
deal with parsing expression grammars
use what's called a recursive descent
parser and a recursive descent parser
basically treats each one of these rules
so the things along the left-hand side
here also called non terminals a treat
shows just as functions so basically the
the two things in blue they're these are
just function calls effectively and you
know if you've ever written recursive
function that calls itself as the first
line of that function then you probably
understand why this is not going to work
right it's it's it's simply just
infinite recursion it keeps trying to
satisfy the expression by by itself so
that's why you can't use left recursion
in a recursive descent parser but it's
actually quite simple to fix and a lot
of people tear their hair out about how
to deal with left recursion but but the
real simple fix is that you just use
iteration instead of recursion all right
and this is something that that a lot of
people know from programming that you
rewrite almost any recursive algorithm
as being an iterative algorithm but a
lot of people kind of forget this when
it deals with when that when it comes to
language grammars so to use iteration in
in this in this grammar we just have to
use the star operator and this is just
like a regular expression so star means
you can have zero or more repetitions of
whatever's inside the brackets there so
now that we've fixed our grammar let's
try parsing the new grammar and yeah it
parses and everything all is good except
you may notice that it's this this parse
tree that it generates here is kind of
weird it's it's like just a bunch of
nested arrays and it's not like that
nice parse tree that we saw from a
suprema that had all this great
information you may also notice that the
number 10 up here got parsed as like
separate digits so this is kind of weird
right I it's a little bit hard to work
with if if you have to visit like look
at each number individually so let's
look at how we can fix that we can fix
this using something called semantic
actions so peg dot j s basically allows
you to embed little snippets of
JavaScript code inside any of your rules
and you can use these to customize how
it builds the parse tree so we're gonna
edit our number or number rule down here
and we're gonna add this identifier
digits so we we have a name with which
to refer to the things that got captured
and then we just add a little snippet of
JavaScript code to join those digits
together into a single string and that's
going to make it much easier to work
with and when I run the parser again I
see that it looks much nicer I've got
you know the number 10 there rather than
the individual digits another thing that
can be useful in when you're working
with peg KS is to insert as
snippet of code at the top of your
function some of your semantic actions
may require you know helper functions or
whatever so what you can do is actually
just put brackets at the top of your
grammar and insert whatever JavaScript
code you want so maybe instead of just
returning a string to represent my
numbers maybe I want to actually build
up a real parse tree right so I can
introduce a constructor function here
that will create a node and then in my
semantic action I can use that
constructor to to create my nodes in the
parse tree so that's really all there is
to parsing a simple language MPEG KS but
you know this language doesn't really do
anything right it's just we parsed some
numbers and operators but how do we do
something useful with it so I promised
in my Brian just held up the 5-minute
five minute sign for me and I promised
that I could teach you how to create
your own language that compiles to
JavaScript in five minutes so it's
perfect timing and I think I can do it
so let's start with the the arithmetic
remember that we had before we're gonna
throw away all this stuff that we don't
need because that arithmetic grammar
works still part of our grammar I'm just
gonna hide it right now at the top level
we have an expression so I want to
introduce a new top level rule here from
my new language and that rule is for
variable declarations and I've just used
deckle here for shorts and what I want
to do is have variable declarations that
are in the style of small talk I don't
know if anyone's familiar with small
talk but rather than saying var x equals
whatever small talk uses colon equals
four he actually uses it for assignment
but in this case I'm going to use it for
variable Declaration and assignment so
declaration consists of an identifier
colon equals and then
expression so let's define identifier an
identifier is just like JavaScript it
can be any sequence of digits letters or
underscore digit the number zero to nine
letters are a to Z in lowercase and
capital and notice I said Zed so I
really am Canadian and we're going to
throw in a new top-level rule here
because we want to have multiple
expressions in this language right our
will grammar only handle one expression
and so a program in this case can
consist of well it can consist of
nothing actually or it can be one or
more expressions that are separated by a
period so small talk uses a period kind
of like Java Script uses the semicolon
right and and I'm a big small talk fan
so I'm going to use that in my language
so let's take a look at what this looks
like now when we try and parse a little
snippet of code with it so I'm just
going to parse something simple you know
x equals 2 plus 5 and y equals 3 and it
works which is which is cool again we
have this really nasty looking parse
tree that it's kind of hard to do
anything useful with so we can use
semantic actions to fix that now when
you're trying to write a language that
compiles to JavaScript there's kind of
two approaches you can take if you're
really making a full-fledged language
what you probably want to do is actually
build up a parse tree and then have a
separate code generation phase where you
walk over the parse tree and generate
the code but I'm going to kind of cheat
here and because my language really kind
of maps to the same semantics as
JavaScript I'm just gonna build up
JavaScript strings and then at the end
concatenate them all together and I'm
going to have my program so that's what
I'm doing for the variable declarations
here I'm basically just building up a
string that begins with var inserts the
the variable name puts the equal sign
and the expression and a semicolon and
when I parse my little example looks
much better right so so you can see I've
actually got like you know something is
starting to look like a like a
JavaScript variable declaration there I
just need to clean up a few other things
and just like before we can use semantic
actions to clean up the parse tree so
I'm going to concatenate everything
together in an expression and flatten it
and it's getting better so now now I
actually have a full basically valid
variable declaration there and I'll do
the same for the per at the program rule
to basically clean up the rest of it and
bam I actually you know there we've
actually compiled a language which is
not JavaScript although it resembles it
into valid JavaScript
so this is not quite a Turing complete
language so maybe I've cheated a little
bit here but you can imagine it's it's
really not that hard
so you add in things like if statements
and loops so if any of you have thought
like you know I really want to design my
own language but I wouldn't know where
to begin I encourage you to go home you
can sit down and write something like
this a full language easily in a day so
I hope I've you know encouraged you to C
compilers is not being just this tool
that that kind of you you use but never
look at but but they're actually
something useful you can use to do
things you know both in JavaScript or if
you're looking for you know if you've
always wanted to design your own
language and I see people sometimes
using you know grep and and regular
expressions to do things and I just want
to like you know tell them like don't do
it it's so it's so error-prone it's
really not that hard to write a simple
parser for simple languages so if you
like more information I encourage you
guys to go check out on prima and pegged
ojs packages is still pretty early on
and I and I think you know they love
contributors and people reporting bugs
and if you'd like to see more details on
the code that I showed it's up on github
you can check it out there and there's
also a URL for my slides so thanks oh
and I should add if you have any
questions please come see me after the
talk thank
you